Netflix is bringing James Cameron's
Titanic back to streaming and some fans
are not happy in the wake of The
Disappearance and implosion of ocean
Gates Titan submersible which was on a
journey to go see the wreckage of the
real-life Titanic fans think it's kind
of an insensitive move to advertise the
fact that the 1997 epic will return to
Netflix on June 18 2023 five people
including Ocean Gate co-founder Stockton
Rush boarded the Titan to visit the
Titanic but the submersible never
resurfaced a few days later a search
team found debris scattered 1600 feet
from the Titanic site and announced that
the Titan likely imploded soon after
losing contact with ground control about
90 minutes into its dive the debris is
consistent with a catastrophic uh
implosion of the vessel Cameron's movie
is one of the most celebrated films of
all time receiving a record-breaking
number of oscars and still gaining new
fans every year but fans think that
Netflix is making the complete wrong
call with this re-release naturally they
took to Twitter to express their anger
with the streamer and they definitely
didn't hold back when you got nothing
you got nothing to lose whether or not
the arrangement to bring Titanic back to
Netflix long predated the Titan
submersible's implosion which it very
likely did widely advertising Titanics
returned to Netflix definitely felt like
a gross move to a subset of fans over on
Twitter one user revealed they canceled
their subscription to the streamer
posting in part Netflix marketing
director you know how we could really
capitalize on the tragic deaths of these
people put Titanic on Netflix for some
easy cash because 31.6 billion dollars a
year in Revenue isn't enough how broken
and sick does your brain have to be to
think this way another user echoed these
statements writing Netflix is
overstepping the boundaries of decency
with this timing people died in a tragic
accident that the Titanic site to now to
capitalize on the moment to Garner
viewers is beyond this tasteful this was
clearly a common sentiment with another
user writing not the right time for this
Netflix the world is talking about the
Titanic for the wrong reason and your
team should wait for a month or two to
release the movie on your platform let
the families maritime and Diving
Industries mourn in the midst of the
Titans disappearance when it was still
unknown whether or not the submersible
could still be found in the passenger
safely rescued Cameron himself actually
spoke out because he's something of an
expert when it comes to exploring the
wreckage of the Titanic deep submergence
diving is a mature art as of the making
of this video Cameron has completed 33
Journeys to see the Titanic wreckage
several of which were researched for the
film and he also explored the Mariana
Trench in 2012 and is submersible that
he designed himself so he does know a
thing or two about situations like this
before the submersible's Fate was
determined Cameron told CNN he suspected
it had imploded based on his own
experiences the only scenario that I
could come up with in my mind that could
account for that was it was an implosion
and when everything was confirmed he
remarked to ABC news that he like many
others could see clear parallels between
the Titan and the Titanic Cameron said
I'm struck by the similarity of the
Titanic disaster itself where the
captain was repeatedly warned about ice
ahead of his ship and that he steamed at
full speed into an ice field on a
moonless night and many died as a result
it's very similar tragedy at the exact
same site it's astonishing and really
quite surreal two and a half miles down
3821 meters pressure on side is three
and a half tons per square inch on July
1st Titanic despite the outcry will be
available to watch at Netflix